this is a production of Cornell
University it's it's an honor to be here
and it's a special honor to be invited
by students that's my first student
invited seminar and I think you all know
that you know that's my that's a high
plank to take so thank you all for
choosing me to come here and moreover I
think my students here are so driven and
setting such a high plank that they
asked me to give two seminars and told
me we're gonna zoom in to see both of
them so I've ended up essentially
component composing to talks and so if
I'm not good to talk about some of the
aspects of the research and you're still
interested about it just feel free to
talk about to talk to me about it and so
they talked to yesterday I spoke in
Geneva and spoken for about our some of
our applied work and wheat and some of
our functional work and today I've
decided to focus on what we're doing in
the evolution of the plant immune system
and as was mentioned I just recently
moved my group actually back home to my
home department from England where we've
been before for about four years and I'm
quite excited to be back in the US and
meet the colleagues here and establish
more of a connection with us colleagues
and if you wouldn't if I want you to
take back maybe one in one thought from
this it is that right now is a good time
to look at the plant genomics and look
at the evolutions and specifically what
we try to do is to decode information in
the plant genomes and by that I don't
mean sequence inanity by that I mean ask
specific biological questions hypotheses
or any questions that we can answer with
the genomics and if we understand the
rules how the genomes are gold and
what's encoded in there we hope that
they we can engineer are the systems
what's been driving my interest in
science for a long time is basically
what is the difference between a
diseased plant and a healthy plant and
as a whole lot we think about it and two
ways one is a disease one that has a
disease has to be a host has to
accommodate the pathogen and provide
whatever the resources and nutrients
that it needs and at the same time you
know the pathogen needs to be able to
suppress immune system and a healthy
blonde can be either a known host in a
way that it just doesn't provide the
right environment for the pathogen
doesn't have the correct accessibility
completely or you can have an active
immune system that recognizes the
presence of the pathogens ELISA and then
what I'm going to speak today is about
that letter art about the plant immune
system and the question the big
biological question is how can plant
evolved new pathogen recognition
specificities how does that system of
old and here I want to bring back the
Red Queen and if you'll remember that's
the moment in the Lewis glass Lewis
Carroll where Alice means the Queen and
the Queen says well this place you have
to run just twice as fast
to get somewhere else and if you just
need to run to keep in the same place
and of course that concept has been
applied repeatedly to coevolution and
especially coevolution of blood pathogen
interactions and the reason why I'm
bringing it because when I was the first
year graduate student I happened to read
this review where a Stephen had Drake
from UC San Diego he applied that
metaphor to mammalian immunity and he
made a case of even with the most
advanced immune system that we have
where we can recognize literally any
epitope write anything we still get
disease we still yeah the common cold
every year so the pathogens no matter
how advanced the pathogens will still be
able to overcome it and we still need to
keep up
what about the plunks right so the
plants life cycle is much greater than
my curbs
they don't have specialized in new cells
so how do they stay ahead and how do
they engage in the battle and we think
about the immune system from the
perspective that the most important part
and this is the generation of a
diversity which upon the pathogen
infection provides enough material for
select beneficial variants and then
amplify them now of course some crops a
lot of times that's the first very first
level that's been lost we would plant
monoculture we losing that diversity the
first step and on the two approaches
that my lab does both wet lab and by
pneumatic research and I'm guilty of
being both of these guys on the wet lab
side right we study particular pathways
we study very specific creating
something we still don't know you know
we still don't know exactly how plant
immune signaling happens we still have
this black box and the same time this is
also us just my lab we can look at all
of the data and we can generate all of
the answers at the same time so how and
I think like the main kind of the main
outstanding question right now for all
of you students out there how do we
bridge that gap how do we reconcile on
the bond phonetics of big data analysis
with the mechanistic work at the pathway
and I think it's evolution so if we look
at it in the context of evolution we can
answer some of those questions so what
do we know before I go into a pond
immune system I want to quickly
summarize the last 35 years of research
in respect to the plant cell and what we
know today is that in plant cell there
are two major systems of monitoring the
environment and responding to the
pathogens specifically one of them is a
receptor like kinase as of
pattern recognition receptors that
monitor the environment outside of the
cell and we all know that no matter
where King which Kingdom pathogens come
from they all had molecules that reveal
their presence they are specialized to
this pathogen see there's a fliegel in
or it's a chitin and that recognition
signals on the first level of immunity
what else is now is the pathogens from
all of those kingdoms they evolved
abilities to inject specialized
effective proteins within the cell the
mechanisms how they do it are different
but all of them do that and those
pathogens arrive defectors there have
they have two roles they have the role
in suppressing this immunity and there
also have a role in modifying the
environment to enable the infection to
make the plant cell force AB to burn the
plant susceptible for the infection and
while this first role of the effectors
and suppressing the immunity has been
well studied the second role of the
effector modifications of the plant
metabolism on the plant cell is much
less studied in those effectors they
again they reveal the presence of the
pathogen now inside the cell in the
recognition of those effectors is a
mediated by intracellular receptors that
we really like to study they're called
analyst or nucleotide binding Lucian
creepy proteins and they can recognize
the effectors in two different
mechanisms one of them is direct
recognition meaning like the ligand
receptor interaction between a pathogens
right molecule and and then along
evolutionary if you think about it
that's not very efficient because plants
I told you they have a mate immune
system they have a limited number of
receptors and using this receptors to
monitor all of the effectors from all of
the pathogens evolving all of the time
that's just not realistic
so what plants of all the if all the
second mechanism which is similar to the
first one but instead of monitoring the
factors directly they monitor their own
plant proteins so instead of having
recognition of non-self
have a recognition of modify itself and
that is right away that's a much more
limited number of proteins right and
moreover what's known is that different
pathogen effectors they again and again
they target the same plantation because
at the end different pathogens they want
pretty much the same things from the
blonde they want to get the nutrients
the president needed so what ends up on
that by monitoring the plant proteins
that are modified by the pathogens and
monitoring specifically those hubs that
can be worn as modified by multiple
pathogens plants gain evolutionary the
ability to recognize different factors
and different pathogens right so that
makes sense and so Anna Lars is a
relatively large plant family it is
present not only in plants but also in
mammalian innate immunity and what you
can see from this figure is a there is a
quite diverse numbers of analyzed and
both plants and animals we have five
runs that we have ways of rapidly
identifying any Lars and genomes and we
use that on based on the central and B
archetype binding domain that's typical
to all of the analyzed and when we talk
about the analyzed and we think about
the function immunity we want to look at
the and a lot I've ER CT right and again
I want to quickly summarize to you
what's known to contribute to an a la
diversity across a species and I'll tell
you today to do stories about this to
different aspects one is a copy number
variation um as you've seen an Alaskan
vary greatly in the copy number and
that's both are due to tandem
duplications in the genomes but also
present actions variation then there's a
lilyc variation course point mutation
but also gene conversions and what we've
added to the to that scheme is gene
fusion so an Alaskan fuse with other one
genes
and then there is epigenetic and post
transcriptional valuation of analyst
with alternative splicing and smaller in
a based regulation so today I'm going to
tell you two stories one is related to
the copy number variation in blonde
genome and another to this gene fusions
so this is my first graduate student
Aaron E and Aaron is absolutely
fantastic she came to the lab back in
Earlham with no bond time at experience
and she wanted to do a PhD in genomics
bioinformatics and studying at a la
revolucion and the very first thing that
she picked up within probably the first
two months is how to annotate those and
a loss and look at the copy number
variation of the and the loss across
genomes so she got a hold of the scripts
and she analyzed every ponder you know
she could get he had her hands on and
she made this graph where we looked at
the total number of Anna laws in the
species relative the total number of
proteins with idea being like if what we
see in the variation of number of unless
is just reflection of expansion of the
proteome you know we should see a trend
and we do say that and then she was
really interested to see is there any
type of correlation with an Elan number
and lifestyles at once she done a few
different analysis and she came up upon
a very interesting phenomenon which
again started as a side project and
that's kind of the first papers
publishing what she found is there was a
striking correlation in NL a copy number
between all terrestrial plants and some
of the aquatic plants that in both
monocot and monocot and dicot lineages
they moved back to the water so it says
it's a secondary aquatic lifestyle and
when she looked at the evolution of then
laws in both monocots and dicots only
including really high-quality reference
genomes and asking the question what
happened in this aquatic species
in both mono colleges great reduction of
the analyze and in dire chords that was
even more pronounced so what look to us
is that with moving to the aquatic
environment the response lost their
analyzed well they're very close
relatives had much greater and a low
number and the question then the
question was well did they what type of
analyzed did they lose did they lose all
of them they do change sounding that
what's going on
so stood on a tree so this is a tree
based on that common central and barbed
domain and included some reference
species together with the aquatic
species and what we could quickly see is
that those aquatic species lost most of
their in a lock light and retained only
a few not the same ones in each aquatic
species and then there was an expansion
so those aquatics and blue of those
credits so while most of those an alive
been lost in particular was interesting
to us as the dicot species really lost a
complete branch of tear and BS emeliza
this here is a signaling domain on the
n-terminus we know that and monocots
those proteins are actually absent most
of the time but then in daikon was
striking that those particular claims
were lost so the next question there in
us was well if if they lost they and a
loss did they also lose the signaling
components downstream of them or did
they retain them and so she started
analyzing all known adopts the signaling
component and grouping them either in
those effector targets of protein
starting that we know targeted by
factors or this is the the signaling
components downstream of the analogs and
this is a hormone sa hormone signaling
even downstream of that and what we
realized is indeed there was a group of
genes downstream of analyze that's been
convergently lost in both our clades of
aquatic species and those group of genes
include EDG is called EDS one
for inside 101 and the striking was
striking for us and we know that those
are the proteins that form a protein
complex so it's a multiple components of
a signaling protein complex that been
converted in lost and B we know that
those are major signalling component
downstream of those tear and DSL a lots
and we've done a lot of analysis looking
at annotation assembly quality RNA seek
just trying to see maybe those students
be missed but they're just nowhere to be
found
no species so this is kind of a Erin's
overview of this gene so this on what we
basically found that in addition to the
losing the receptors these genes lost on
this downstream components but retain
whatever is downstream remember they
didn't lose all of the receptors and
they do retain some of the more
downstream component but I was exciting
that makes sense so the next question
Erin asked I thought that was quite
clever is if we look at all genes that
are convergently lost in aquatic
environment what are any other genes
that we might find because I told you
you know there's a big black box here we
still don't know exactly how that
signaling happens and whether we have
all of this controllers right so we
decided to use those species to be able
to say can we do this genomic screen
task if we can find some other
components lost in this pathway and the
what we call them we call them address
per se retained because that was a
criteria for us they had to be retained
on species on land and aquatic loss or
astrology and I'm gonna outline two
different methods how we use it one of
them is called ortho MCL it's a very
canonical method applied nor mix where
you can have protons from
friend protein-coding genes from
different plant species and what older
mcl does it are builds protein families
and those combine protons to group them
in the families and we've an asked that
we wrote custom scripts to ask what are
the protein families that we see that
are present in all the terrestrial
species and loss and all aquatic and for
the sake of computational resources we
did it separately for monocots and
dicots and then identified ornithologist
genes against each other and this is the
results if we just look at their die
cause is quite number of genes about
been lost if we look at them all of
codes there is another clade but they
all overlap and you know converging
launched it's actually quite small with
surprising shots so and the second
method we were you know we were happy
but we're also not happy because it's
just one computational method and the
big dependency barrel is how it calls
whether something is a one gene family
or not right and what we knew is that
ortho mcl can it cuts gene families
quite conservatively it can split
sometimes purchased from different gene
families so we adopted a second approach
it's called genes take two family which
has a very similar approach of grouping
the proteomes
into the orthography but it it does it
does slightly different algorithm behind
it if you're interested their algorithm
is published and there's a galaxy
workflow and if you've ever worked with
the plant ensemble and they're
ornithology gene trees the algorithm
behind this gene stick to families
adopted from on some plant ensemble
Khepera
on database and here we've we're able to
group all the proteins together and we
had another what we know is that G that
gene seek the family it tends to be on
the opposite it tends not to split genes
and to the kind of a smaller family but
group
together so in the end if we overlay
those two analysis we have our ortho MCL
done in a dicot species monocot species
that have both of them in g6 two family
there are only five genes that no matter
how we cut this genomes how we look at
them
there are present and there are overlaps
that I told you here between our MCL
monocot dicot and this genes are called
slightly differently among the five
genes that we found our our this is now
you know unbiased this is our EDS pad
four and a few are the genes such as NR
g8 one then since we've done the
analysis they've been shown to be how
they analyze that are required for the
receptors and moon-god is what we
decided to focus on we decided to say
well we'll take everything that both
doors and see how cold and we'll take
everything then gene sixty family cold
and we'll take that overlap and try to
look what's there just for us that's
very exciting there might be like new
candidates want immunity there in the
next question that we asked was what's
their expression profiles can we also
sort these genes based on the known
expression profiles are any of them
induced your immunity similar so we know
hideous one is induced during immunity
and maybe other we were always concerned
thinking um maybe there are other
pathways lost in aquatic plants so if we
again look at all the expression data
sets that are all banned we took all the
expression data sets for about a hundred
and forty data says and include
microarrays and recording seek or our
topsis and slightly smaller number but
still a big number for rice and we look
what are the conditions under which
these genes are groups of this gene
significant groups of this genes are
differentially expressed and we did
basically there are only two conditions
that came up Juan was biotic stress
we were happy kind of we are so we
aren't digging in the right place and
there were a significant group of those
astrology pnes that were differentially
expressed during P syringae and Magna
Bertha arising in the rice and inmutants
of the this is a sa signaling in
different mutants they were they were
also affected and interestingly was only
one other condition that showed
differential expression of the central
genes and there was drought and for us
it was kind of an aha moment the aquatic
plants lost some of the components of
the drought response but it was also
nice to see that we might be predicting
not just the immunity so to summarize
this type of analysis what I told you is
we use comparative genomics to identify
known components that are lost in plants
they change their habitat aquatic from
terrestrial and have retained a new
terrestrial and we have a putative
placement of some of this we known G's
but also some of the other genes here in
the pathway and also there are
candidates that we can play some some of
the drought responses what is striking
to me and to my last slide on this part
is not just that aquatic plants lost if
they would have lost completely all of
them the laws and all over this pathway
I would have been ok fine but what's
striking is that they retained some of
the analyzed right and they retained
some of the components signaling so what
means that they rewired their immune
response to adapt to that aquatic
environment similar with the drought
it's not like they just wiped out we
don't need the child anymore
we could actually you know you could
drought stress a dark weed or aquatic
Sun but it looks like they lost some of
the major regulators you know this
response that means they probably
wired the response that was left
so the second quick project that I want
to show you and all of the data and most
of the data over 50 percent that data
I'm sharing today is unpublished or its
own bio archive is we noticed another
outlier in this case and it's maze maze
has a really well sequence genome
absolutely great annotation but it has a
low number of and a loss compared to its
sister species again we decided to
understand what was going on there and
first thing we've done again it's a
phylogeny and here's a I could show you
the different scenario contrasting
scenario of a phylogeny of again and the
laws on the central NPR domain between
sorghum and meso sorghum very closely
related species and what you see that
Mays crude it's analyzed across the tree
and retained one member from almost
every plate but it's greatly reduced
number and we know that it's not armed
I'd like to say sort of them expanded
this and the laws we could look at more
of assess your species it's indeed that
may somehow lost them now the sequence
genomes now and what I talk about here
is elite maize varieties that underwent
extensive inbreeding and domestication
so the project that we started and we
started we've reached out to the news
community and the makes communities
absolutely great they sent us seeds they
sent the samples they sent us
unpublished genomes we started to
address this question where this
reduction could be due to inbreeding or
domestication and for that we picked
samples that represented elite maize
lines and we know the number there or
maize landraces and until sent to you we
were able to pick out crossing and
inbreeding bread lines and that would
address the inbreeding hypothesis and as
well as domesticated non-domesticated
relatives and we designed a sequence
capture for NLRs in the capture war
world sequencing annal are specifically
scauldron seek but it's essentially just
capturing that family with specialized
baits designed to hybridize to the
sequence and pull them down for
sequencing and we now sequencer about 80
members across this clade looking at the
most diverse species with pag bio so we
have Pogba along reads that will able to
address us this question well that's
kind of giving you a flavor which can
happen to analyze very different sites
and areas and different lineages and for
the the rest stock I want to quickly
focus on gene fusions and want to bring
these two examples
rs1 our ps4 and IgA of 5rg well there's
a two known and the laws that are
functional and what's been unusual about
them they have those extended non
canonical domains they've been known for
a while and until their functional
analysis shown the function of this
domain they've kind of forgotten and
what were these domains do they serve as
bait for the effect of the for the
passage and affection molecules they
resemble those proteins that are
targeted by the effectors and they serve
as integrator decoys into the end the
laws that furniture those factors the
question we ask is if we can look all of
their in the loss can we look as this is
phenomenon that's been described for two
genes as widespread
it can't across the plants and how many
more fusions we can find and though it's
a long story short we did find that
about 10% of these and the laws they
have fusions to other plant genes
that's a widespread phenomenon and those
are quite diverse fusions since then
many other and we turn those Enel ours
with integrated domains since then
several other Anna laws have been
recognized and what are those integrated
two mains tell us right this is a
genomic screen that could identify
things that might be targeted by the
factory right so we could by the looking
at just identity of this fused base we
can tell what are the other proteins
might be important for plant pathogen
interactions so we did that CAG analysis
looking at the homologs of those
integrations and we found of course
plant pathogen interactions map kinase
is on top of it but where we able to
found is quite a number of metabolic
pathways and I talked a little bit about
that yesterday that are enriched in
those integration this is a plant
cellular pathways monitored by plant
immunity and likely modified by the
pathogens so how can analyze tolerate
this fusions we had two hypotheses one
is that an allure I DS format random
terrain and a la evolution and it's
forward by adaptation and the second is
that there are evolutionary hotspots in
this diversity there's a specific place
where those fusions happen more often
and - long story short we general made a
tree we mapped on the tree where this is
nine grass genomes where those NLR ids
were and we found that were several
clades that were highly enriched in
those fusions and so that's been
published on the go quickly and again
there's one clade in which there was
more than a 60% and lost fused very
diverse domains we looked in weed
because it's a bully ploy and we looked
at different sub genomes and we see that
even in in the sub genomes of wheat
there are different fusion see them to
the ornithologist for me all Auguste
sequences so that's again what's shown
here it could be two closer related
homologues
and they can have different domain
attachments this is an ongoing
evolutionary process and we've spent
quite a lot of time now looking at the
mechanisms of how that happens we were
able to tell that it's an inter
chromosomal transfer of genes and it's a
copy of base forces so what we the model
how we think evolutionary what happens
is there has been an adaptation of
particular and a law to accept this
little fusions and
together with the Mathmos school ah we
were able to identify a protein motif
and was specific to this claim that we
now think might facilitate regulation of
the analyzed by these fusions and the
interestingly on a structure that
protein motifs maps to the last
hydrophobic cap of the LLR that kind of
closes that ll on surface now what of
can also see from the slides that those
and the laws often function in pairs so
they're always they often require now
they and a lot so now the question we
asked if this is an ala that has an
integrated bait attached to it and a
known ones have a helper now rather
often genetically linked so it's a
perfect basically genetic stack where
the two genes are correlated together we
asked like whether this is true again on
the genome-wide level and we've designed
an algorithm to look for those had to
have pairs and looked for a course any
at a loss what type of paired
relationship we have and this is
analyzed belonging to different clades
what we saw that our clade of interest
with integration 16 often paired with
another clade like seven and this is
just a circus thought if you imagine a
phylogeny in between that displays all
of this paired relationship this make
one clade 16 plate Salem so we now
postulate that see seven that plate
seven is this helper played while this
Mick one is the sensor play that baits
for the pathogen and what I want to
bring to your attention as well as I
showed you those suitcases of herb
Dobson rice where those this paired
relationship help assess the
relationship and if we look in the
context of the evolution of analyze
across monocot and dicot this is
essentially a convergent evolution those
help a sense of pairs that are in had to
had a reputation in ER Abraxas and rice
they've all been dependently in this to
quite how I had to have for sure
No and another helper Glade here that's
important for solanaceous I've been
starting for a while it's again it's a
that's a gimmick and Topalov convergent
evolution thinking about the mechanism
so far I wish I could tell you the exact
mechanism but so far we've excluded
retro zones positions because this
fusion still have insurance and we don't
see any transposon signature associated
with it and we've been looking farm okay
couple of minutes like thinking yeah
5-10 minutes um we've started looking
within species so we've now I told you
okay there's great the amount of
diversity happens across species so far
only total across species we've been
starting to looking within species and
specifically looking at those NL our IDs
highly holding plates this is 13 by
species this is published now by some of
our collaboration during where if you
look at the low side this is scrambled
eggs those law say that Harbor those and
the Lazos and a live I'd either they've
also rapidly again this is closer
related slide a different species at
that time bracket building pie genome
came out there was no and Ally analysis
so we decided to look when we first saw
that number of analyst very it may be
twofold within the species number levin
lr ids was there most of the NLRA IDs
were newly formed they were present only
in wanjina but not any others some were
segregating they were present and half
of the genomes other half of the genomes
and some of them were fixed so we'll
look at those fixed we will looked
what's happening to them and this is
showing us something in between Brock
Ian rice for that locust you know it's a
highly divergent locust in rice its
present and project
it's another duplication and this is a
schematic like this is why my last set
of slides where I want to show you
within a variety species how much
evolution happening and those are the
law will say this is the reference
species right if we look just in the
reference and this is the NLR ID here in
the in the purple there are
synthetic genes around it there are a
lot of duplications that happen to this
gene and moreover in many strains there
are gene sized insertions they're just
coming of this focus and these genes
that come into this locus if we look at
them closely
they resemble integrated domains so we
think those are the donors the donor
material that can get integrated this is
much bigger kind of genomic question now
that we are working with that I want to
summarize what I just doing and Alaris
amazing plant family they and a lot of
perjurers very grandly in aquatic cons
there's low but in if we look at crops
as low as 30 and cucumber to over 2000
and wheat maize has a very unusually low
number and a lot that we're trying to
understand why an aquatic plants are
convergently most don't analyze and
downstream signaling components and then
those analyzed they also good markers
for understanding how the plant patients
confuse with each other and function and
also they allow us to dissect on microbe
interactions revealing what might be the
proteins are targeted by the pathogen
but then I want to thank my group
especially Aaron and Andrew who moved
with me from Norwich to Berkeley as well
as all of the lava lama i and our
collaborators
[Applause]
so I think we have time for some
questions and I just asked that for
people online or on the and the
recording can you just repeat the
question and the in microphone so are
there any questions from grad students
or postdocs and okay yeah go ahead our
genes and terrestrial and terrestrial
species what do you think it's the
evolutionary driver okay that's a really
good questions we don't know the exact
answer but we can think of it two
different ways either those Enel ours
are not needed in aquatic environments
so they present a cost that can be lost
right or they're detrimental or some of
the signaling pathways with some of
their responses are detrimental we don't
yet know how to distinguish it besides
maybe transforming duckweed to see if we
put them back does it really kill it in
terrestrial plants giving their absence
is simply in shedding baggage we think
that those loss of function changes are
so the question for the remote audiences
whether the aquatic plants compensated
by as I understood the question by
expanding other protein families for
example or relying on other pathways
more heavily and the second part of the
question was whether
was that loss especially a job that was
the detriment because it was detrimental
right whether losing it was essential or
was just a passive kind of loss of the
genes yeah quite a class yep our aquatic
plants source of innovation straddles
that's an excellent question I have a do
we pre proposal submitted on that and I
have a dark weed collaborator at j-bay
who is Greer duckweed and drought stress
it all ready and ready to extract RNA
from it so it is it's an unusual
direction for my lab but I'm happy to
take it if we get the funding I do think
that it is dark weed it is a sort of
innovation I think they rewired because
the the downstream some of the
downstream drought response genes
they're there it's just those master
regulators are not and that's the same
with let's say the immunity the sa
pathway is there they and pure pathways
there but this kind of the middle layer
and some of the upstream components are
not so I do think it's a case of
rewiring and I think it's might be a
source of novelty and adaptation during
the ringing because I got a little
distracted but there were are there and
then is that across as well yes so the
question is whether there are hotspots
glades for fusions and the answer is in
cereals and monocots yes there is that
hotspot claim unless arable answers
there isn't that we found and the next
question is whether there are genomic
locations and we do think that the
genome architecture and the surrounding
loss I do play a role but what we think
it's basically it's a several lost idris
tributed across the genome so it
wouldn't be just like one locus and if
we look at let's say brac your eyes that
isn't that is conserved that the
presence of the NL are IDs and that
diversity is in the synthetic locus so
I've kind of skipped that probably fast
that's an excellent question so any
questions on line feel free to hop in
give them a second and if I Jin why
looks like you have any questions
loss of EDS one pad for and loss of NL
ours which one happened first we don't
know because there's not enough
resolution in the genomic sequences of
the relat you know kind of the relatives
and they're on there's nothing remaining
of those signaling component genes over
all aquatic plants do you undergo genome
reduction and it's just those are the
genes that are convergently lost in all
of the species we don't what we could
tell is okay we can tell in one of the
aquatic plants which has a remaining
let's say one and a law that analyzed
going out so def and some of the
analyzed we see is well what what
happens basically did lose a ds1 pad
full and we'd still see some of the
analyze just kind of on their way out
they would lose the motifs there would
become suitor genes and the sequences
yeah so we have designed Rancic on weed
and we sequencing about 60 lines as well
analyze our hypothesis
there when a distinguishes hybridization
polyploidy from again domestication
all-day event so we're sequencing while
a panda love while the tetraploid weeds
called wild Emma and comparing it to the
domesticated durum wheat to make that
distinction but there's absolutely right
something unusual on the opposite
spectrum happened and wheat where it
there's an expansion of analyze and it's
not just a sum of the diploid
progenitors deployed weeds have about
400 500 and a loss you know times 3 in
that hexaploid that should be 1,500 what
we see is close to 3,000 interesting
join us for lunch I'll be coming up
right now and please show me what's
gonna thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at Cornell edu